I owe you a huge debt of thanks because
as you know,
about a year or so ago,
and to back it up a little bit,
all of my fans know that
I've had a long running feud
with a guy on our staff,
named Jordan Schlansky.
Jordan Schlansky is a
total pain in the ass
and
is a big know-it-all.
And then you did me this amazing favor.
I took Jordan to Japan.
And he, Jordan says that he
knows everything about Japan.
Also
his, one of his favorite movies
of all time is "Karate Kid",
and then a "Karate Kid
II" the whole franchise.
And, he started to shoot off his mouth,
as I knew he would,
about how he knows that "Karate Kid II"
was shot in Okinawa, I think.
And I secretly asked
you, would you tape a,
would you take a message of you
straightening Jordan out?
And you did that.
Your entire fascination with Japan
stems from the fact that you saw
"Karate Kid II",
(laughter)
and that it was filmed in, where?
Okinawa,
Okinawa.
I have a message here for you.
Please press play,
and hold that out to the
camera as you watch it.
Hi, Conan.
It's me, Ralph Macchio.
Listen, I'm sorry to interrupt,
I just wanted to tell that Jordan guy,
that all the scenes in
"Karate Kid: Part Two"
that was supposed to be Japan
actually shot in Hawaii.
(audience jeering)
Oh, and Jordan,
those weren't real dinosaurs
in "Jurassic Park".
(laughter)
Sayonara.
I cannot tell you what that meant to me.
That was so sweet.
He's still recovering.
(laughter)
You appeared out of thin air.
His childhood hero appeared
out of thin air and said,
"Jordan, I side with Conan.
You're wrong."
It was perfect.
I, you know, it's funny.
'Cause you get asked to do,
or I've gotten asked to do,
you know, these sketch things,
you get the pitches,
"Hey, would you do this
for whoever, whoever".
And it's usually a one off joke
that this show gets a lot more
mileage out of it than I do.
[Conan] Yeah.
This one came to me
it's like the perfect time with the
with a couple of suggestions,
each one better than the next.
I said, you know what, I
was in my office I said,
okay, lemme just throw
this up on the phone
and see if it works.
And it just,
it killed man, it killed.
We were playing it on
the set of "Cobra Kai"
when we were shooting it and everybody was
going, "I could get to Macchio."
Because that was sort of the,
the pronunciation of my name.
Yes, Jordan was so mad.
He was so at me in that moment,
he couldn't just take the joke and go,
"Okay, pretty good you got me."
He just kept saying,
"Oh, you think you're so
big because you've got,
you're the star of the show.
Well, I could get to Macio.
I could get to, you say it's Macchio!"
(mumbling)
Your hero!
How do you not know it's Macchio?
And my single favorite line of that,
of that year probably was,
your childhood hero came out of my phone
and took a shit in your mouth.
(laughter)
'cause, you delivered it beautifully.
I laugh out loud every time,
and subsequently now,
and maybe it's because of
"The Conan O'Brien Show",
and we'll give some props to Jordan,
even though I know you hate to do it.
(laughter)
I have been to Okinawa,
where some shooting of
"Cobra Kai" Season Three,
Ah.
Which,
I cannot talk too much about,
but I can say it dives into
the origin of Miyagi-Do Karate.
[Conan] Oh wow, okay.
We learn a little bit,
some secrets of past history
that is new to the audience
and to LaRusso, my character.
And we actually went
to Okinawa to shoot, so
I think you guys put that in the ether and
some--
So yeah,
retroactively you've proven Jordan right?
Yes I have.
But not after killing
him and squashing him
and shitting in his mouth.
All right, we have a clip here
from "Cobra Kai".
And
I believe this is where
basically you are finding
out that your old nemesis,
Johnny Lawrence
has set up the Cobra Kai
Dojo.
Dojo, in the mini mall.
You realize that this
he's brought it back.
You can't believe it and
you go in and there's
kind of a quasi confrontation here,
which is kind of cool.
I think that sets it up.
Let's take a look at this
clip from "Cobra Kai".
Is there anything else you need me to do?
I'm sorry, sensei but...
Sensei?
Really?
Oh my God kid, I don't
know what he's told you,
but you shouldn't believe
a word this guy says
or you're going to end
up exactly like him.
You and I,
this,
you know, we're done.
I'm right here, man.
You know what, I'm really happy for you.
This is a, I'm really
happy for your success.
And,
I'm happy that
and again, thank you so much
for destroying Jordan Schlansky for me.
That's right.
I owe you anytime you
need any video from me.
If you can ever find someone
who's a big fan of mine,
I'll do the same--
I'll start looking.
Start looking.
And I,
it won't be that difficult.
(laughter)
I love "I'll start looking".
Well, you set me up,
you threw me a beat (mumbles)
(laughter)
That over the middle of
the plate I had a swing.
Thank you.
It was an illegal kick,
that you just gave to me.
The first two seasons of "Cobra Kai"
are streaming now on Netflix and,
it is a really fun show.
If you're not watching it,
get started.
'Cause it's a joy and
Ralph, thank you so much.
Really good talking to you.
I appreciate it, man.
Thank you so much.
Yeah, stay safe.
Take care, man.